but in the last few decades Scholars
like MOSI idel have gone against this
idea and instead argued that not only
does it exist in Jewish mysticism the
idea of the mystical Union is indeed
quite prominent and common we've seen in
this episode many examples of a kind of
unitive language from the earliest
writers such as Pho of Alexandria we
find the idea that the human can Ascend
to God and even unite in some way in the
case of Pho though it doesn't seem like
a full Union with God but with an aspect
of god named main the logos perhaps most
prominently in the ecstatic cabala and
writings of people like abolafia who
talk about the goal of DAV C or cleaving
precisely as a kind of Union where in
abolafia words quote he and he become
one entity Inseparable during the ACT